wir sprachen vorhin drüber beim Wachstum
lassen uns die USA echt alt aussehen
aber dafür hat Deutschland jetzt endlich
auch seinen eigenen Trump den einmal
Hubert ja wirklich also jetzt ohne Ende
parallel wie Donald wurde auch der Hubi
lange nicht ernst genommen verlacht und
seine Fans lieben ihn egal was er tut
72% der Bayern finden es richtig das
eiwanger im Amt bleibt na klar die
sogenannte politische Kultur hat in den
letzten Tagen ein paar Kratzer gekriegt
aber hey dafür wissen wir jetzt endlich
wie Krisenkommunikation geht Momente für
die Ewigkeit auf alle Fälle seitdem
Erwachsenenalter die letzten Jahrzehnte
kein Antisemit keine Extremist sondern
ein Menschenfreund
ja ein Satz wie ein Verkehrsunfall meine
Damen und Herren ja seitdem fragt sich
ganz Deutschland hat der Aiwanger
eigentlich ein Kommunikationsberater und
wenn ja was macht der beruflich ich
meine ja wie Sie wissen rechtfertigte
Ruby sich im Wesentlichen mit
Erinnerungslücken ja man könnte auch
sagen
man könnte sagen er zieht ein Lupen
reinen Scholz die Sache mit dem
Flugblatt war für ihn ein Zitat
einschneidendes Erlebnis an dass er sich
deshalb auch kaum noch erinnern kann ja
und der Mann hat sich doch entschuldigt
für was genau weiß er zwar nicht mehr
aber das ist doch gar nicht der Punkt
hauptsache man zeigt Reue und Demut wie
ist es denn möglich dass es bei ihnen im
Schulranzen gefunden wurde dieses Papier
glauben
so jetzt die schlechte Nachricht da hat
er völlig recht weil der Hubert ist
irgendwie geschafft hat seinen Skandal
umzudeuten eine Lupen reine
opfererzählung wir die normale
Bevölkerung mit dem gesunden
Menschenverstand sollen mundtot gemacht
werden von derer wo kein Eliten da oben
ja das ist ein Kulturkampf statt gegen
Land mit Aiwanger in der Rolle des
kampfdaddy praktisch ja
ganz ehrlich man kann über den Hubi hier
denken was man will er ist eindeutig
Deutschlands größte bierzeltbegabung
hier pünktlich zum wiesenstart nächste
Woche im Handel
bring das Bierzelt zum Kochen mit
hubsies wiesennetz in München fliegt man
niemals draußen
[Musik]
die normale Bevölkerung geht total abzu
das bisschen Flugblatt war ich ganz
allein sag mein Bruder wow ein völlig
unglaubwürdiger Partykracher jagt den
nächsten
tausendplatz
transportiert DJ gesunder
Menschenverstand singt endlich mal was
Sache ist ich war noch nie anziehen
wiesnitz so geil da besamt sich die Kuh
von ganz allein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gewesen steht auch vor der Tür so und
ich sage spätestens seit dieser Woche
weiß der Aiwanger ihm kann gar nichts
mehr passieren eigentlich hätte ja schon
nach Erding rausfliegen können als er
damit erigierter Aorta und roter Birne
gebrüllt hat man müsse sich die
Demokratie zurückholen als gewählter
vizeministerpräsident von Bayern und da
war keine 17 soweit ich weiß aber sehen
wir mal das Positive liebe Freunde
Bayerns bestes Comedy-Duo macht jetzt
weiter es ist eine tolle Nachricht oder
ich finde schon ja ja es ist ja so
Markus Söder braucht den Hubert als Mann
fürs Grobe weil er neben dem wird wie
ein sensibler Feingeist und weil er weiß
vor wem seine Bayern wirklich Angst
haben die Grünen passen mit ihrem
Weltbild nicht zu Bayern und deswegen
wird es keine grünen in der bayerischen
Staatsregierung geben meine Damen und
auf gar keinen Fall auf gar keinen Fall
ja und ich dachte Bayern wäre so reich
warum muss der selber seine
gebärdendolmetschen es ist ja Wahnsinn
ich habe da Leute für neuerdings so nur
Nummer für mein Verständnis damit ist
kapiere die Grünen passen nicht zu
Bayern aber indem man goge der
wochenlang die Öffentlichkeit über ein
antisemitisches Flugblatt aus seiner
Jugend beliebt schon ja ja okay wollte
nur mal sicher gehen fürs Protokoll
jeder Mensch hat natürlich das Recht
Fehler zu machen vor allem in der Jugend
ist doch klar völlig logisch meine
entscheidend ist doch nur
wichtig ist nur was der 52-Jährige
Hubert Aiwanger aus der Geschichte
damals gelernt hat und ich fürchte ja
das falsche hier wurde von langer Hand
geplant den aibanger fertig zu machen
mit dem Ziel die Freien Wähler zu
schwächen eventuell sogar die Grünen in
die Landesregierung zu bringen ja von
langer Hand geplant gut das klingt jetzt
für den Laien erstmal weit hergeholt und
nach einer Verschwörungstheorie wir
haben es recherchiert das ganze ist wohl
tatsächlich ein von langer Hand
geplanter Start streicht der grüne im
Grunde ein Putschversuch der Hubert der
kann da überhaupt nichts dafür wir haben
hier Welt exklusives Material aus dem
Jahr 1988 da liest der Hubi in der
großen Pause wie immer sein geliebtes
landserheft und dann kommt ein
18-Jähriger namens Toni Hofreiter lenkt
ihn ab mit seinem neuen panzerquartet
hätte der toni hat sich immer schon für
Panzer interessiert so und der weiß
schmuggelt die damals achtjährige
Annalena bärbock dem Hubert die Nazi
Flugblätter in den Ranzen um ihn so 35
Jahre später fertig zu machen absolut
perfide meine Damen und Herren ja ja
ich kann Ihnen sagen wir haben Annalena
baerbock mit den Vorwürfen konfrontiert
sie sagt es war ihre Schwester so ich
hatte vorhin ja spaßeshalber gefragt hat
der Aiwanger eigentlich einen
Kommunikationsberater jawoll hatte der
Mann heißt Alexander Wipprecht
Redenschreiber und PR-Experte zur Stunde
live mit Hubert Aiwanger beim
traditionellen Knödelfest in
niederbrecht wie läuft's läuft super und
sie sie können Sie Ihren spöttlichen
Unterton direkt sparen ich sage nur
erste Umfrage seid Flugblatt Geld freier
Wähler 4% rauf plus 4 %
genau hier die normalen Menschen die
lieben den Hubi ja macht ihr mal genau
so weiter da oben in eurem Elfenbeinturm
jede neue Schmutzkampagne bringt uns
hier unten 1 % mehr Sekunde ich
muss ganz kurz aufpassen was er gerade
wieder sagt danke für diesen wunderbaren
empfand es tut mir gut meine Damen und
Herren
also wenn er frei redet da bin ich immer
so ein kleines bisschen nervös Moment
ich muss mal ganz kurz mein Ball ja
der Hubi deshalb cool und warum weil er
als einzige die Sprache des Volkes
spricht der den den versteht der Bürger
wenigstens
bist du noch damals als er die Corona
Abstandsregeln so wunderbar erklärt hat
wenn sechs bis acht Leute jeder mit
seinem Kumpel kommt dann kann der sich
natürlich jeweils mit seinem Kumpel der
seine Bezugsperson ist an einen Tisch
setzen und mit 1,50 Abstand sitzt der
nächste Kumpel mit seinem Kumpel aber
die können nicht sechs mal zwei an einem
Tisch sitzen weil er nicht mal die
ersten an einem Tisch sitzen dürfen
besser kann man sogar nicht machen
also sie sind rund um zufrieden auch mit
der Performance der letzten Tage ja
natürlich jeder Mensch hat doch das
reicht doch mal Fehler zu machen sich
weiter zu entwickeln klar manchmal da
benutzt immer noch so Vokabeln nicht die
sind jetzt im ganzen Kontext Drittes
Reich sagen wir mal super optimal das
Video das Thema umstritten ist und die
Leute einfach sehen hier sollte offenbar
jemand ja
vernichtet werden wenn man so haben will
okay das war jetzt unglücklich
formuliert auch noch vor vernichtet so
ein Denkpause machen
haben wir aber mal besprochen ich habe
den Hubi sogar meine Liste mit Begriffen
gegeben die wir ab jetzt eigentlich
komplett weglassen wollten also hier
vernichten Schornstein die ganze Palette
Moment was was sagt er jetzt gerade
wieder aber wo sich nicht richtig finde
ist meine Damen und Herren wenn man aus
ja sorgen die 35 bis 40 Jahre
zurückliegen jemand später in seinem
Leben konfrontiert bis zu seiner
beruflichen Existenz Vernichtung ach du
scheiße
das kann doch nicht wahr sein
mach dabei
nein jetzt nicht Alex vielen Dank
ich glaube nicht dass das hier gerade
noch jemand sieht Wetten lieber heute
show Fans wenn ihr das hier noch seht
schreibt in die Kommentare gerne
tasknechts schauspielerische Darbietung
hat mich zu Tränen gerührt und abonniert
gerne den Kanal danke
und die endcard macht ihr jetzt hinter
jedes Video klar auch wenn ich nicht
darin vorkomme